In the real world, things don't just
appear or disappear out of thin air.
They move into place.
Instantaneous changes can be
confusing or disorienting.
>> Just as we learned how applying
lessons from the physical world to
create tangible surfaces in our UI
helps to convey information about them.
Applying real world principles
of motion can make your
interface more understandable.
>> Think of your user interface
as existing on a shared stage.
Elements move in and out of this
stage in a controlled manner.
>> Right, in this lesson we'll look at
how you can use motion to create a more
continuous experience, how we can teach
your users about using your UI and
how we can also provide
moments of delight.